are you from originally
um I was born in Long Beach and grew up
in the city of Hawaiian Gardens and grew
up with no my mom she was a single
working parent and she worked most of
the day so we barely even got to see her
all right yeah my dad left when we were
when I was five and how was your
childhood being a lot of fun I don't
know besides being alone I was sexually
molested by a stranger at age eight I
mean was abused by my sister like
physically beaten then aged 12 like 11 a
half 12 years old I was sexually founded
by my uncle my mom's brother so I once
but twice
how how did you get the first thing
[Music]
who's the stranger um I know who you
just found you to Parker yeah well age 8
an 8 year old child shouldn't be left
alone but I played ball a tennis so I
went I get my sister taught me off and
then after my male tennis practice I was
just being in the park until somebody
came to pick me up which never happened
because I ended up running into this guy
he made up a story about how his
daughter lost her charm bracelet or
something and he don't know so
eight-year-old innocent eight-year-old
child wouldn't you know so I fell into
that trap I mean I was only eight
you know that's just the kind of person
I was at that age I was really friendly
and didn't he take a second glance at
people that could have been strangers or
harmful to me so I went through the
whole park helping him supposedly live
for this charm bracelet his daughter
lost we knit up across the street at the
high school and he forced me to perform
oral sex I'm not a DJ so and then aged
well my mom's brother who happens to be
my uncle when I fondled my breasts and I
told my mom and she likes che me I've
been through a lot of situations it's
like I didn't I'm 41 years old now
I came to downtown LA after them
sexually the sexual fondling is my uncle
at age 12 is when I came to skid row
he came to page 12 mm-hmm when I wasn't
in jail or rehab or you know whatever
but
pretty much from age 12 to 41 it's much
I've been through a lot
I made a lot of people you know some
good some not so good age 12 was okay in
here and wise I kind of tested with weed
for a little bit and then I went from
that to crack cocaine and I've tried
crystal but solely the only dude I
haven't ever used it I've never used
your own goodness I have four boys you
know because of my addiction my oldest
and my third boy was raised by my sister
from one of my older sisters in
Riverside my second oldest he got
adopted out because he had a lot of
because I used practically my whole
pregnancy with him and which like at
that at that point in time the way my
life was going when I even when I first
found out I was pregnant with him I was
pretty far along like I really didn't
care anymore than my life was it you
know I felt like my life wasn't worth
living so I tried to figure out a way
not to tell people to kill myself but I
was doing it to both of us at the same
time so not at first no because like my
first one I wasn't on drugs so that was
like one of the clean times that I had
so I found out when I spread out when I
found out that my oldest said I was
bringing it I was like already three
months before I found out and my second
one I ain't no I was variants that's
pretty much why I used back to the money
pregnancy
do you have any here dude
in my second all this who happens would
be the one I had respiratory policies or
than you medicate with him hostage
um I don't prostitute myself sometimes
if I like what I use for personal use
I'll take some of that and if somebody
ask me you have this amount okay I like
to keep my Heather going because I value
myself as a woman a lot more than I used
to
I'm not gonna say I've never done that
because it would be alive but like I
respect myself and value myself more as
a woman now today even though I still do
what I do I don't have to put myself out
there like that or put myself at risk of
getting killed by somebody you know
dating a woman but like it has its Inc
the dating rules like sexually they have
sexual relations with a woman and they
end up doing horrible things the word I
don't I can't put myself at risk like
that I just can't see myself doing
and what your goals here um I haven't
really thought that far hand because
every time I try to like fight people
some people saying you don't plan things
ahead because those might fall through
yeah I have actually I do you agree um I
do myself
yeah would trigger you go back thoughts
about old people places and things
that's usually when triggers people to
come back
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]